back a couple more steps that would have
been good
so tyrese and desmond doing it in 39.1
and this is the last chance
scotty barnes and tyrese maxie
[Applause]
wow that one fan is really excited
scotty barnes
kent oh in our first miss of the magic
shot
maxie
can't get it
scotty
oh here come the memes don't do it again
come on scott history destiny layup
house of highlights fire it up don't
make it for come on don't do it no way
no
no
no
are you serious right now i think he
hits that one and then maxie
the ball is tipped and that will be a
highlight that we will remember for a
long time oh my god maxie and barnes hug
it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
defense though he did have some trouble
some travel problems
he might be jet lagged a little bit man
he just got here today
today
even more of an excuse wow so those are
your champions tyrese halliburton
desmond bain
man that was you know what it was nice
to end it on that yeah
i hope they're okay a little bit of fun